Stephen you're your own mom you can do
whatever you want I love that you know
for an episode that kind of seems
legitimately pointless there were one or
two really legitimately funny lines it
is Oh I mean really the only thing that
happens in it that's like a connection
to story or anything is like they find
the pod great Stephen gain control
that's interesting um but yeah
everything else just kind of like
Stephen goes with these friends and
finds the pod he's goofing around with
it you know not cool but not a smart
thing to do obviously and then the gems
come almost using technology gel I'm
just gonna fuck around with it yeah
Jen's come almost destroy him and
they're really angry at him for very
rightfully so I the only one who had
like when they were sticking the spears
through it and everything had flashbacks
to that Tom and Jerry cartoon where Tom
tries to present himself as a gift in
the box and Jerry stabs the fuck out of
it slices it in half then opens it up
and then also person they can't show it
as I got to know some assignment says is
there a doctor in the house like when
when garnet broke that thing in half I
want to looking at me like oh this is
just like this era doctor I love the one
cartoons are too gory for in the cartoon
that they can't show what killed me is
that in the next scene in that cartoon
Tom's sitting there formulating some
other plan but not only does he bandages
all over his back on one giant one yeah
listen so how does he put effect Jesus
Christ Santa Barbara but uh yeah should
give you an idea how much we remember
from this episode because already
talking about imagery but but no no no
okay and she was it actually was a good
episode I actually thought it was pretty
decent likes it it's it's not okay so
they almost kill him and everything you
know see we're very disappointing like
lay off man he's just a kid and then
they're like you know what let's
unground him I'm like uh what the hell
did I miss if it started off with them
being like really aggressive on him Amy
don't get me wrong they wanted to like
look for every single piece and stuff
like that but again he's a gem he's part
of a
he talks about how he wants to be taken
seriously and wants be part of the team
and you know okay he's gonna make some
mistakes here and there which he already
has and stuff but it's like there's
nothing in the beginning to indicate
they were being like especially tougher
than usual or anything like that and I
don't know I kind of know this was a big
screw-up
they've been tough on him like the whole
time I mean he still can't watch
television which to a child that age you
may as well just kill him um but at the
same time I don't know and the other
thing is but everything is he just went
through this major life event and you
were just complaining in the previous
episode that pearls like I don't
understand human emotion like I didn't
seem like they're really doing anything
for him either and he may have a little
bit of PTSD going now cuz it's like shit
I've seen things and he's stressed out
so I you know maybe you could argue that
instead of giving the TV bag they should
have just called it a wash considering
he was running around with alien
technology but you know I I don't know
and I think their point was it's just
like yeah like did we just had an earth
invasion uh he nearly broke up with his
girlfriend all of this shit went down
he's got all of these things on his mind
you know let him have a little fun that
shouldn't be the fun he's having granted
you shouldn't run around in alien
technology that's how you fucking get
Independence Day that's how it starts so
but yeah maybe if he was doing something
that was not as harmful like that just
seems like a big what the hell are you
doing thing uh yeah what you brought up
cuz like when he when they're driving
and he does bring up the whole backstory
he talks about I'm kind of my mom and I
don't know the gems like me necessarily
because they feel I kind of took her
away and they well that's I me I mean
that that that's a really nice scene but
it's like that one little moment feels
like that's kind of it it doesn't feel
like and grantees are very short
obviously but doesn't feel like there's
enough building up to kind of that
ending like hey we should really really
lay off uh aside from that scene which
is a good scene but it's very short as
just some dialogue there was the time
just kind of acting like normal Stephen
um so I I don't know it didn't feel as
earned to me like I don't dislike the
episode necessarily but I felt to get to
that ending I'm like it I could have
been bookend a little better it seemed
like here's the idea of the show today
all right is he acting like normal
Stephen like all we've seen so far like
is the the episode with the invasion him
going nuts and nearly breaking up with
his girlfriend and this episode how much
of normal Stephen have we really seen
like this may just be him slowly getting
back to normal but then he had that
scene in the car no but they were but
they're also kind of for not for him but
they were talking about their stuff so
he kind of shared - um and like I said
that's a good scene but everything else
just seems like you could have shared
anything he could have said it sucks
just not to have TV like he went there
so I don't know it seems like it left an
impact on him
maybe you lie you insensitive prick no I
mean it's no I know what you talk about
where it's like okay so here's like you
know you don't need a ton sometimes just
a little scene like that is enough and
we talk about this all the time
sometimes all you need is a look all you
need is a line all you need is whatever
you know so that could poor innkeeper
okay and keep in mind he did yes he got
into the alien pod but he also was doing
the responsible thing initially until
peer pressure kicked in yeah and their
point which in his current mental state
ethic was legitimate it's like hey you
got online like you have all this
pressure on you and that's when he gave
in to weakness it was like okay maybe
right like maybe we should just cut back
and have a little fun and but he was
initially he's like guys this is gem
technology you can demand idiot onion
head hair or whatever like throws the
rock at it and like it did they confirm
eeeh like are they is he related to
onion cuz he was talking about being a
DJ pilot I'm just assuming yeah
but yeah he's like you know my dad wants
to wear a raincoat and stuff like that
and fish and stuff like that so the
first thing I thought is onions father
so I thought maybe they're related I
don't know
I'm just assuming yes but they both have
cats I'm sure the fans will answer that
one so um but we also thought the three
of them I've ever laid to the gems as
far as I know everyone's saying I mean
there's no confirmation that they're
connected in any way like a future
episodes but it's like they're designed
so similar which is just so odd um but
uh yeah I mean I don't dislike it um you
know it's it's fine to that I think I
like the episode more than you did no
I'm probably uh like I say I love maybe
like two more if there is a stronger
like if that ending was built up a
little bit more I mean I see where
you're coming from like you don't need
that much but I want like a little bit
more at least there was no Ronaldo that
is true
um well and even though was it the
artist kid all of the shades or whatever
like in the one episode I'm like okay I
get him like I don't like and we dislike
him he just doesn't do much for me he's
a really funny life my life and my
fairies daughter does like the gems are
invading whatever he's like not cool
earth forever
I'm serious that's gonna be my reply as
a social media is inundated with French
flags and this and oh we should out of
these people it's like well how can you
honor these people and not these people
and well how can you be upset about this
terrorist bombing but not what's going
on in Syria how many lives it is that
I'm just like shut up I'm just gonna say
not cool
Earth's forever Oh what about the other
planet uh uh yeah that's not Marla mark
play don't give a shit about Mars
yeah weirdos back we got Pluto back up
no love for Pluto no love for flippy
it's like a mini planet or sometimes if
this what about the Sun huh
what a hug you don't give a shit about
the Sun what about Mars we found water
on there right right right
you know if somebody cares about
something just let them care about
something and go in the view on little
life this is just this is not crazy out
there right now that I you know not cool
Earth forever does seem like just a good
just remember even the episode ends with
it just earth forever earth forever um
what I had to thought was gonna happen I
felt when they were taking the pictures
like the selfies and stuff like that I
thought like peridot was gonna somehow
on social media
you see the selfies be like haha that's
where they are me you know baby come
together that would have been awesome a
uh but um yeah I hey Liam technology
Yolo so um I need it's okay I like I
said I still think it should have been a
smaller thing he should have been doing
than messing with the alien technology
from something that almost killed him
and you know it bowties I mean peridot
almost killed him and this thing Frank
well I guess that Jen's almost killed
him but still um and I would like to
book tend a little bit more uh yeah can
we talk about something more important
what's that how these episodes are
arranged on Amazon yes let's go fuck I
just can't tell all the fans right now
all the people there saying like no no
no look you something's out order
everything but trust me it's at first it
doesn't matter but you gotta watch these
in order because this is apparently like
the end of season 2 and whether the
episode just before is the Oh what the
who was it where Connie is calling and
um you know trying to figure out what
happened to Stephen and stuff like that
like all of that according to Amazon
happened before the giant hand comes
down and guard is revealed to be do
people and literally would have seen
what was the previous episode call ah
count forgetting now um but yeah well
disclosure yes wheel if we had watch
this in the order that Amazon gave it to
us we would have seen full disclosure
before the reveal with garnet and the
alien invasion yeah and I would have
been sitting here going the fuck did I
miss
yeah I thought well bin like some sort
of weird setup at Emma's aren't like
that the show hair cuz the show starts
in the middle of stories I don't know if
this is on Amazon I don't know if this
is on Cartoon Network
i I don't know who's fuckin responsible
for this but you should be ashamed and
go sterilize yourself who does that like
completely out of frickin order and like
early on I would be like okay well that
doesn't matter the order we got another
going on but that invasion was a huge
fucking plot point and I would have been
sitting here scratching my head going
what the hell are they talking about
I felt like it would have been a joke
like if I start at full knowledge and
there he is on the phone you know Steven
what's going on what's going on you know
it's like Oh like we're not supposed to
know what happened or something like
that but ya know it's um not cool right
forever earth forever